MALE SPEAKER: Welcome everyone.
Today we have a very
special guest, Sean Carroll.
And thank you so
much for coming here.
He's written a brilliant
book, "The Serengeti Rules."
And this is his fifth book.
And I was just asking him,
you've already written four.
Why the fifth book?
And it was just joking around.
And he said, this is
an important story
that needs to be told.
And there are things
that we've learned
at the molecular level,
things that we've learned
are the ecological level.
But there are sharp contrasts.
And it's a story of those
contrasts that he wants
to highlight through this book.
So without giving
much about the book
away, without any
further ado, actually,
let me just welcome
him to the stage.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please join me
in welcoming Sean B. Carroll.
[APPLAUSE]
SEAN B. CARROLL: Thanks, very
cool to be here-- first visit
to Google.
I have that creepy feeling that
you know a lot more about me
than you're admitting.
So we have to get there.
And thanks for spending
your lunch hour with me.
I'm going to try to tell
you a couple of stories.
I guess my major hope
is that you'll come out
of here with a little bit
different view of life,
and maybe just a little
more hope and optimism
about our ability to do some
things on this planet to put
her back in better shape.
So my tales today are
going to largely take
place on the Serengeti.
But before I go there, I want
to give you some context.
In the summer of 2014,
I'd just finished work
on a film for the
Smithsonian Channel called
"Mass Extinction."
And in the course
of that film, I
worked with a couple
of ecologists,
sort of examining where we were
at this time in the world's
history.
And I learned by going to
places like Yellowstone
that even some of our
most protected places
were having certain issues.
And like you, I saw
headlines like in newspapers
about what was going on with
wildlife across the globe,
and even stories like
this about the plan
to build a road through the
middle of the Serengeti--
a paved road through the
middle of the Serengeti.
And really, it was just
my own personal concern
that maybe these places
weren't going to be around
or not going to be in the same
condition in a decade or two
from now.
But I took my family
for the first time
to the Serengeti in 2014.
And there we are at the rather
simply marked entrance gate.
You sort of expect
the famous Serengeti,
that there's going to
be bells and whistles,
and food trucks right there.
Not at all.
And in fact, this is the
view going through the gate.
And as you can see,
it's a gravel road.
And it was late
June, but the grass
was kind of brown
and fairly high.
And as we started
driving in, I started
getting kind of worried.
I'm the only
biologist in my clan,
and they weren't seeing
anything for a little while.
It's like, this
isn't the Serengeti.
And we did see after a
little, while there's
a lioness in the tall grass.
I thought, wow, this is
really going to be hard.
You can't get out of the
vehicle because of the danger.
So there's six of us
in a vehicle for days.
And if this is what
we're going to see,
I'm going to be thrown out
of the vehicle, I think,
is what's going to happen.
But as we drove
on that same day,
we started to see little streaks
of green, little bits of water,
a few acacia trees, and
then came over a rise
and around a bend,
and this is what
it looked like with a GoPro
hanging out of our vehicle.
360 degrees around us, virtually
all I could see were zebras.
There was a big water hole there
that they were drinking at.
I would say probably a
couple thousand animals
in our field of
view, and then up
on the horizon, a big troop
of elephants walking down.
This is home footage.
I know this is a terrible thing
to do to your friends, which
is vacation movies.
But these are all
shot by my family.
So from that point
on, the Serengeti
have offered just
an unending canvas
of animals of all
shapes, sizes, and colors
from, sturdy little
warthogs to lounging hippos
and sleek impala and giraffes.
What can I say?
I never got tired of
looking at giraffes.
I don't know what it was.
There's probably 20,000
in the Serengeti.
I don't think I saw all
of them, but I saw a lot.
I don't think I have to
tell you what this is.
She shared about
half a day with us,
going up and down out of
her tree, eating a gazelle.
And as I just looked across
this incredible landscape,
sort of a little uneasy
feeling crept across me.
Because I'm a professional
biologist, but I realized
I didn't understand
what I was looking at.
I've worked indoors all my
life at a different scale.
And I know a few things
about how biology works.
I know a few things
about how life works,
but again, generally at the
cellular and molecular scale.
And as I got asked
questions by family members,
it started to get really
sort of embarrassing.
Because dad, why, dot, dot,
dot-- and I couldn't answer.
I've studied the making of the
animal kingdom for 30 years.
I've worked on the genes
that build bodies, and create
stripes on animals, and
spots on butterflies,
and things like this.
So I know a lot about that
sort of invisible scale
of the world, but not anything,
really, about the larger
scale-- not until I
left the Serengeti
and thought I really need to
understand how this works.
And I think especially
here at Google,
the theme today
would be the numbers.
What I was not prepared for-- I
was awestruck by the Serengeti.
But look, I'd watch these
films as a kid and as an adult.
I had read books, etc.
But I was not prepared
for the numbers of animals
that were on the Serengeti.
And I didn't understand
why, for example, there
were so many
wildebeest and so few
topi, which is about
the same sized creature.
Now, what I do know is
that in biology, certainly
at the molecular scale
within animal bodies
and within our bodies,
everything is regulated.
And what I mean
by that is there's
more than 20,000 substances
inside your body.
And the amount of each of
those substances is regulated.
Some things are
very, very abundant.
very, very scarce.
So whether it's
a salt, or a fat,
or a hormone, or an
enzyme-- all those things
are maintained in a
fairly narrow range
by processes within the body.
And the same thing is
true of the cell types
in your body-- white cells,
red cells, kidney cells, liver
cells, etc.
There's a particular
range of cell numbers,
and those are
maintained as well.
So everything is regulated.
And this understanding,
for example,
of how these things
are regulated
has led to a
revolution in medicine.
So the strategy for how this has
gone on for the last 50 or 60
years in molecular
biology-- the study of life
at the molecular
level-- has been really
to figure out the rules
of regulation in the body.
And that's involved-- to use
a sports analogy-- identifying
the key players, which are
key molecules that regulate
a process, to understand
how they interact
with other things in
the body or control
the amounts of other things.
What governs their play?
And as I said, this has
led to a revolution.
Because once you
know those players
and the rules of regulation,
then we can intervene.
And that's what
medicine has been doing.
And so to give you a couple
of examples-- what medicine
can do, for example, is restore
a missing player-- something
like insulin in the
case of diabetes,
or in the case of
cholesterol, regulation.
If there's abnormally high
levels of cholesterol,
to intervene in the regulation
of cholesterol synthesis.
And that's what Lipitor
and other statins do,
which has transformed
cardiac medicine.
So what I want to do today,
though, is ask the question,
are there rules
just like the rules
that operate within our bodies?
Are there rules that
operate on a larger scale?
And that's really the
main theme of the book,
is understanding these
rules of regulation.
And of course, if
there weren't rules
that operate on larger scales,
the talk would be over.
And we'd be quickly
to the lunchroom.
But yes, there are rules.
I've called these
the Serengeti rules.
But what I want
you to keep in mind
is that these rules
operate all over the globe.
You can see them
in operation there.
And I'm going to use
sort of the storybook
animals of the Serengeti to
bring them to life for you.
And then in the last
little part of my talk,
I want to talk about how we
can use these rules to preserve
or even cure some of the ailing
ecosystems around the world,
and hopefully, give you some
concrete examples of how
this knowledge is power.
I want to start with a little
history of the Serengeti
that I think you might
find interesting.
The Serengeti went through
various stages of protection
in the 20th century,
not really becoming
a full-fledged national
park until the 1950s.
And really, tourism was
insignificant until well
after World War II.
It's not the sort of thing
that people were into.
So not much was known
about the place.
And when biologists
showed up, they
did sort of the obvious thing,
which is they looked around,
and they said, how many
animals are actually here?
And the first biologist to
do that were a father and son
team from Germany named
Bernard and Michael Grzimek.
And this is a clip
from a documentary film
they made in 1959.
It will show you how they
counted all the animals
in the Serengeti.
And that's Bernard on the
left and Michael on the right,
with their very handsomely
decorated plane.
And what they did is,
with two other spotters,
they would fly with open
doors, cross the Serengeti,
fly low and slow.
And this in the days
before digital technology
is how-- this is also the
animation circa 1959-- there
you go, prior to George Lucas.
And here we're going to get a
view of-- here they are flying.
That's a lot of animals to be
counting 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10.
But that's what
they're doing, flying
back and forth in a grid.
And you're seeing largely
wildebeest on the run here.
But they're counting
all the large mammals
that they can see from
the air, big enough to be
able to be seen from the air.
And they did this for a few
weeks' time in January of 1958.
And we'll see a shot out
of the back of the plane
here in a second.
All right, so what did
they actually count?
They counted 99,481 wildebeest--
not 482 and not 480.
This is done with
Teutonic precision.
57,000 zebra or so, 5,000
topi, 1,800 buffalo,
only 60 elephants.
Because of the ivory trade
in the 19th and early 20th
centuries, elephants were still
pretty scarce in the Serengeti.
366,000 large animals in all.
Now, they were very
impressed with this number.
And they were very impressed
with their technique.
They felt that they missed no
more than 10,000 animals out
of that figure.
But in a book they wrote, also
called "Serengeti Shall Not
Die," they expressed
their concern.
They thought was there really
enough plains, and mountains,
and river valleys,
and bush areas
to maintain the last giant
herds still in existence?
An answer to their question
would soon materialize.
But it wasn't the answer that
they expected or probably
most feared.
By the mid 1960s,
within a few years,
there were changes taking
place in the Serengeti.
And when this
young undergraduate
from Oxford arrived,
Tony Sinclair,
first came to the
Serengeti in 1965,
his intention was
to study birds.
But he was assigned to one
of the first aerial surveys
to follow up on what the
Grzimeks had done in 1958.
And in the course
of that survey,
it was realized that something
was going on with the buffalo--
that whereas in 1961,
about 16,000 buffalo had
been counted, there
are now 37,000 in 1965.
That's a pretty big
jump in just four years.
And so they asked Tony, who
wanted to come back and do
his PhD in the Serengeti.
They said, would you
be happy studying
buffaloes instead of birds?
And he said, love to.
So Sinclair came back.
And over a span of
about a dozen years,
he did sort of this
first phase of work
that asked a few
general questions.
And this is Tony.
This is, I believe,
a sedated buffalo.
Because he's not like
a buffalo whisperer.
That's not a safe situation
unless that buffalo
is knocked out.
Why were the buffalo increasing?
What explained the
great differences
the numbers of different kinds
of animals on the Serengeti?
And really, the fundamental
thing he wanted to understand
was, why is the
Serengeti the way it is?
So he starts probing
this buffalo mystery.
He continues to
take place in what
essentially became annual
surveys of the Serengeti
animals.
And it's true that the
buffalo population is growing.
In fact, it kept growing
into the almost nearly 60,000
by 1972.
And so this was a mystery.
Why were the buffalo
just blooming like this?
And so Tony started to
do some detective work.
And you could think of the
same sort of hypotheses he did.
Why would you have more animals
of some type on the Serengeti?
One first possibility
would be more food.
Well, didn't seem
like it would be
more food, because the
Serengeti is a big place.
It seemed like the same
amount of grass was growing.
It's a vast place.
There was no sign that there was
more food in these later years
than in earlier years.
What about perhaps
fewer predators?
Maybe fewer buffalo were
dying because maybe there
were fewer predators.
Well, turns out, first
of all, Tony carefully
looked at what
buffaloes die from.
It turns out they don't die
that often from predation.
That's not the major
cause of mortality.
In addition, not only
did the Serengeti not
have fewer predators,
but those counts
revealed that there
are more predators.
There were more lions
in the Serengeti
as the years were going by.
So we eliminated that.
So how else could he
explain more buffaloes
if it's not more food and
it's not less predation?
Well, a third candidate
would be disease.
Wild animals carry
a lot of diseases.
It was known that buffalo had
a fair number of diseases.
And one disease
particularly seemed
like an important
possibility to Tony.
And it's a disease called
rinderpest or cattle plague.
It arrived in East Africa
in the late 19th century.
It hit cattle, so cattle
that are especially
being kept by the Maasai.
It hit buffalo and wildebeest.
So it hit both domestic
and wild animals.
And it was thought at the
time that the wild animals
were the reservoir
for this nasty virus.
The virus could
cause massive losses.
So you could use lose
90%, 95% of your cattle.
So this could be catastrophic
for any nomadic tribe.
But in the early 1960s, Tony
knew that a vaccination program
had started in cattle.
So that a good vaccine
had been developed
and a program came to vaccinate
the cattle all of these tribes
in Tanzania, for example.
So could this be it?
Could the vaccination
program be doing
something that was allowing
the buffalo to resurge?
Well, if you're
exposed to a virus,
I whether it's us
or buffalo, you'll
make antibodies to that virus.
So the way to tell
whether something's
been exposed to a virus
is to get a blood sample.
And so Tony got lots
of blood samples
and then age-matched them
with various buffalo.
And his first Eureka
moment was when
he realized that there was no
sign of buffalo being infected
past 1964-- that the rate
of infection had plummeted,
and the virus had disappeared
from the Buffalo population
the Serengeti by 1964.
So certainly without
rinderpest around,
that could explain the
growing buffalo populations.
So this was satisfying.
But Tony also knew there
was one other species that
was affected by rinderpest,
and that was the wildebeest.
So he started paying
attention to wildebeest.
Now, he had been involved
in annual counts,
but now he was really
paying close attention.
And so what was happening with
the wildebeest at this time?
Yeah, look at those numbers.
So they had reached, by
1977, 1.4 million wildebeest.
So they'd grown at least
five-fold in about 15 years.
That certainly answered
the genics question
that was there enough
food and bush and plains
to support all these animals?
Yeah, there was enough for at
least a million more animals
than were there in 1960.
So the wildebeest
were also booming.
So Tony got blood
samples from wildebeest
and age-matched them, and
found the same pattern
with wildebeest as in buffalo--
that in fact, in wildebeest,
there was no virus
detectable after 1963.
So the virus was disappearing
from the Serengeti.
And the two affected species--
buffalo and wildebeest--
were booming.
This also shattered the
notion that the wildlife
was the reservoir of the
virus, because the vaccination
program was only
taking place in cattle.
So it was by vaccinating
domestic cattle,
it was providing the spillover
benefit to the wildlife.
And the cattle
were not infecting
buffalo and wildebeest.
So these numbers were booming.
So what did this tell Tony?
Well, it wasn't just wildebeest
and buffalo that were booming.
There were other changes
taking place in the Serengeti
that, by being there year after
year, a number of biologist
noticed and studied.
Let me tell you a few
more observations.
Let's see if we can
connect the dots.
One is, fire is an annual
event in the Serengeti.
But as they look year over year
at the amount of the park that
was burned, they saw
that no matter what
region-- north,
south, the plains,
whatever, over all, that less
area of the park was burned
and those fires were less
intense-- so fewer fires,
less intense.
It was also observed that
there were more giraffes.
This is just one
sector of the park.
So giraffes were
increasing, and trees.
Now, they could
tell early on there
were a lot more young trees
growing up in the 1970s.
And by 1980 I'm
showing you a picture
taken from the same vantage
point in the Serengeti
over several decades.
And what it really shows is the
filling in of this landscape,
particularly with
mature trees that you
can see in recent years.
But those are mature trees.
You can see the saplings
growing much earlier.
All right, so fewer fires,
more giraffes, more trees.
How is this all connected?
Here is what Tony
was able to connect.
So let's start back with the
eradication of that virus.
That virus was somehow
suppressing wildebeest
and buffalo populations.
So when the virus
was eradicated,
you got more wildebeest.
What do wildebeest do?
They eat grass.
So with more wildebeest, you
have less and shorter grass.
In fact, they mow the grass down
from about 30 centimeters down
to about 10 through
their grazing.
That shorter grass,
obviously, is
less fuel for fires when
there's less grass around.
OK so fewer fires.
Well, one major
effect of fire is
that fire, being
low to the ground,
is going to burn up saplings.
And that's going to suppress
the growth of new trees.
So that could explain why
you're getting more trees.
And then these trees, and
especially acacia trees,
other food for the giraffes.
So eliminating this virus
from the cattle population
set a whole chain of
reactions in motion
through the wildebeest,
through the grasslands,
through the fire cycle, to
the trees, to the giraffes.
So if you asked Tony what makes
the Serengeti the way it is,
it's a million lawnmowers.
It's a million
wildebeest chewing grass.
That simple, mundane
act-- well of course,
here it is during the big
migration when they're
making a 600 mile circuit
around the Serengeti,
actually mowing it down.
And when they mow it
down, that short grass
provides habitat for butterflies
and things like that.
The trees provide
cover for predators.
They provide nesting
sites for birds.
So this action of mowing
really sets the landscape
for lots of other species.
So the wildebeest are central.
They're the lifeblood
of the Serengeti.
Now, I don't think this
is what you get from TV.
I see a program, certainly
on the African plains,
it's not even a second before
you see a cat chasing an animal
and dragging it down.
So I've not seen that
nice half-hour long shot
of just wildebeest
munching grass.
It takes a little more
patience to get through that.
And in fact, I have
to admit this--
I asked my family
to go out and give
these talks for
pictures that they
had taken in the Serengeti.
I said, I really
need wildebeest,
because I didn't find
a lot in my own camera.
Zebras, giraffes, lions,
cheetahs, leopards,
great birds, ostrich-- we
took all those pictures--
very few pictures of wildebeest,
because they're everywhere.
So you ignore them.
And they're kind of-- sorry,
they're kind of homely.
So they just don't have
that sort of charisma.
But they are the lifeblood
of the Serengeti.
So biologists have
a name for something
that carries out such
an important role.
And this brings me to
my first Serengeti Rule.
You'll get a few of these today.
And that is that
some animals are
more equal than others, to kind
of paraphrase George Orwell.
There's a lot of
animals out there,
but some have a greater
impact on the diversity
of the communities they live in.
And the name for this is
called a keystone species.
And this keystone idea came
from another zoologist working
somewhere else in the world.
So this wasn't discovered
on the Serengeti.
It was just recognized
And that biologist is named
Bob Paine in the University
of Washington.
And he was studying
the intertidal zones
along the Pacific coast.
And he found that this starfish,
this apex predator starfish,
was a keystone species in the
community along the intertidal.
Because much like the
keystone in a Roman arch,
if you removed it-- which he
did-- the community collapses.
It's a little frenetic
animation there on the right,
but the idea is
that some species
have a really disproportionate
effect on community diversity.
And we call these keystones.
Bob Paine also
coined another term
to describe this
sort of relationship,
this sort of cascading effect
of one species on others,
and a really strong
effect, indirect effect,
on other species.
We describe creatures that
do sort of different jobs
in Nature, that occupy different
levels of the food chain,
as different trophic levels.
And he describes this as
a trophic cascade, where
an animal at one level
is having effects
on both plants and animals at
other levels in the system.
And that brings me to my
second Serengeti Rule.
These trophic cascades
are not at all restricted
to the Serengeti.
In fact, they were first
discovered elsewhere.
And they were quite a
surprise, not the sort of thing
that ecologists expected,
that you had creatures that
had a very strong
effect on something,
but it was indirect, not
direct-- not a direct action.
So some species have these
strong indirect effects
through trophic cascades.
So I told you a bit about what's
going on in the Serengeti.
At least one question
might've popped
into your mind, which is, all
right, so the wildebeest do
this lawn mowing.
That sort of sets the stage for
all the other sorts of animals.
They're a keystone.
These cascades are operating.
What regulates the wildebeest?
Do they just keep right
on growing past a million
and a half animals?
No, because if they kept
growing at that rate,
essentially Africa would
be shoulder to shoulder
with wildebeest right now.
So no, that's not their fate.
What happened was
they leveled off.
They leveled off at about
a million wildebeest.
So the 1.4 million was
actually the high-water mark,
and they've since come down.
And why did this happen?
What regulates the wildebeest?
What maintains them at about
a million animals today?
And I want to tell
you this, because this
is a really important general
principle about how many animal
populations are regulated, and
very important to conservation.
So pay attention to the sort
of low end of the curve here.
Here in the early years, once
the virus is disappearing,
they're growing at
the maximal rate.
So I'm just going to come
right this-- happy thumb.
They're growing
at a maximal rate.
So that's virtually
up to the maximum
that it's capable
by reproduction.
But you can imagine that
they could be regulated
in one of two major ways.
They could be regulated
from the bottom up,
by the amount of food, or
really from the top down,
by the number of predators.
So what's going on here?
And before I tell you
exactly what's going on
with the wildebeest,
let me tell you
what's going on with other
animals in the Serengeti.
And I'm going to show you
a graph that, for me, was
one of the most educational or
informative graphs I countered
in the scientific literature.
It really gives me insight
of what lifestyles are like,
or life is like for
animals on the Serengeti.
And what this is is a plot
of the percent of the animals
that die by predation
against animal body size.
So ponder this for a little bit.
So animals could be regulated
by predation from the top down,
or by food from the bottom up.
And if you look at
the smaller animals,
like the oribi and the impala
and the topi-- 100% predation.
I mean, what do they tell
their youngsters growing up?
Some day, Junior, you're
going to be eaten alive.
So that's the life of an oribi.
But if you go to the other
end of this, with elephants,
and hippopotamus,
and rhinoceros,
you see virtually no predation--
no significant mortality
due to predation.
So the large animals have
escaped, essentially,
the force of predation.
The small animals have not.
And they'll potentially
fully die by predation.
And there's a little
bit in between here-- so
buffalo, maybe
about 20% predation,
zebra a higher fraction.
So there's really two
lifestyles on display
here-- either get big
and escape predators.
But if you're that big,
you're, of course, really
heavily dependent upon
food, because you've
got to maintain that
big body weight.
Or be small, but you're going to
have a high reproductive rate.
You're going to
reproduce very often.
Because if you
don't, the predators
are going to eat
you to extinction.
In fact for oribi, at that
size, it's not just the cats.
There's about 10 species
that prey on oribi.
And that includes snakes and
large birds, for example.
So they've got a lot of things
to worry about at that end.
So where's the
wildebeest on this scale?
Well, it turns out that
the wildebeest are largely
food regulated.
Let me tell you how this works.
And it has to do with
thinking about these two
different ends of the curve.
When food per capita-- per
individual wildebeest--
is plentiful, growth is maximal.
So down here, this
is a low density
of animals, and a
high growth rate.
But once the numbers get larger,
the growth rate declines.
Actually, it turns negative.
The population starts to
shrink when food is limiting.
And how does this work?
It works like a
feedback mechanism,
according to the
density of the animals.
As the density of the
wildebeest increases,
there is less food
per individual.
So any kind of
stress, like drought,
will cause a reduction
in the population.
But once there's been that
reduction in the population
in further seasons, there's
more food available per capita,
and the population rebounds.
And that's what stabilizes
the population-- this sort
of feedback between
being limited by food,
and being able to rebound
once food is plentiful,
or in fact Nature culling
when food is not so plentiful.
And this is really important.
This end of the curve is
really important for what
I'll tell you about what goes
on in some other species.
So this leads us to our third
Serengeti Rule there's only 27
of these, so I'm sure we're
going to make it by 1 o'clock.
So the regulation
of some species
depends upon their density.
So just ponder that
for a little bit.
Now I told you
these three rules.
And I've illustrated
them on the Serengeti.
But the main point I want
you to take away today
is that every place
is the Serengeti.
And I thought since
I'm out so close here,
what do I mean by that?
Most places have
keystone species.
They have these trophic
cascades operating.
And they have predators.
They have herbivores, and they
have producers or plants--
green things that are the
bottom of the food chain
that feed the herbivores
that in turn provide
for the carnivores.
And just to drive this
home for where I am,
I'll give you an
example-- a kelp forest.
Monterey Bay is the Serengeti.
And it has these three levels.
And the big, fearsome predator
in the Monterey system
are sea otters.
It's actually otters
preying on urchins
that make it possible for
the kelp forest to grow.
When otters were
nearly exterminated
at the end of the last
century, kelp forest
disappeared across the Pacific.
And just these urchin barrens--
carpets of sea urchins
were all that existed
up and down the Pacific
coast, all the way through
the Aleutian Islands.
Took a while.
This was a major
discovery by Jim Estes
who's over at University
of California, Santa Cruz,
to understand that sea otters
are a keystone in that system.
And it's the regulation
of urchin populations
by sea otters that allows
the kelp to flourish.
The kelp in turn,
provides habitat
to all sorts of
creatures-- much greater
biodiversity when kelp
forest is present than when
it's not there.
So everything is a Serengeti.
And that's important
keep in mind
when we now think about
what are we doing?
How are we impacting habitats?
And what might we
be doing differently
in order to help habitats
be more productive?
So it's the same logic.
It's the same
strategy as medicine--
that the health of
the ecosystem depends
on understanding the key
players, the key species that
regulate community
structure, understand
the rules of the
game, how they govern
the numbers of other creatures.
And then we have to
consider what can we
do to either replace what's
missing, or fix broken links,
or not do things
that break links.
So let me give you just a
couple examples of interventions
to sort of put these
Serengeti Rules to practice.
So here's another Serengeti--
not what you'd think,
I imagine.
A blade of rice is a Serengeti.
I'll show you two members of
that habitat for a second.
This is a plant hopper--
pretty small bug
that likes to actually
suck the fluid out of rice.
So this is the system as you
can sort of think about it.
And you can imagine that
when farmers see these plant
hoppers, they can get pretty
nervous, because enough plant
hoppers can really
damage a crop.
And so the practice
for managing this pest
has been, of course,
to apply pesticides.
And after the Green Revolution
in the 1960s, with improved
rice strains, and rice
covers a huge part of Asia,
these problems
started to pop up.
And so farmers started
using pesticides
year in and year out.
And when they sprayed their
fields with pesticides,
they sometimes got a surprising
result, which was they
saw the plant hoppers
go up up to 800-fold.
And they saw their rice
plants be demolished.
How does this work?
Why would adding a pesticide
actually increase the number
of insects on your plants?
Well, first of all, after
years of using the pesticides,
the bugs have become resistant.
The bugs would just shrug off
the pesticide pay no attention.
Why do they actually
increase in numbers?
Again, took a little
while to figure this out.
But the hoppers are exploding.
And this is the visual effect
of what happens in the field.
The hoppers are exploding
because actually, the pesticide
is taking something out of that
little miniature Serengeti.
It's killing spiders.
And spiders are one
of the natural enemies
of plant hoppers-- not
resistant to the pesticide.
So that when
pesticide is applied,
the natural enemies
are killed off.
The plant hoppers have
nothing to control them.
So pest management
practices, particularly
in places like Indonesia,
had to change radically
to not using massive
amounts of pesticide
but, for example, planting
other plants in and around rice
fields to give refuge
to natural predators.
And giving those
predators a chance
to actually control
the bugs themselves.
And that's still a practice
that's used widely today--
recognizing that having
natural enemies about
is really important.
And that pesticides
are not, in this case,
is a panacea for the appearance
of these sorts of pests.
So spiders are playing the
role here that big cats
play on the Serengeti.
I'll give you another example,
maybe a little more familiar,
which is Yellowstone
National Park.
The observation that goes back
a ways that's really important
is that here's a grove of aspen,
a great symbol of the American
West.
But some botanist
realized that there
was something strange
about the aspen
populations in Yellowstone and
other parts of the American
West, in that most of
them were really old.
There was very little fresh
aspen growth in about the seven
decades from the mid 1920s or
1930s to about the mid 1990s.
There's what you'd expect to be
whole age classes of aspen that
were missing.
So why would that be happening?
Well, one of the
obvious culprits
would be the grazers in
the park like the elk.
And you can see the
effect of grazing up
on the bark of trees.
So why would the
elk be suppressing
the aspen so profoundly?
And one suspect would
be that there's nothing
controlling the elk.
If elk are
controlling the aspen,
what's controlling the elk?
Well, we know that wolves were
exterminated from Yellowstone
in the mid 1920s,
so the possibility
was that maybe the
disappearance of those wolves
was having an effect on
the age structure of trees
and plants in Yellowstone.
Well, that was sort
of put to the test--
deliberately or not-- when
wolves were reintroduced
into Yellowstone in 1995.
And now I can update
you 20 years later
on what's been observed now
that wolves have been put back.
So what could
possibly happen here
is that the wolves
could possibly
control the number of elk.
And that might
influence vegetation
like aspen inside
of Yellowstone.
That's exactly what was seen.
So here's the wolf
populations, which vary
a little bit over the years.
But elk have been pretty
much showing a steady decline
as they are consumed by wolves.
What goes on with the trees?
Well, you see a lot less
browsing in the upper right,
and a lot greater aspen height.
But there are still
some more surprises
than this in store
for the biologist.
If you look at other
sorts of plants,
like willows that like to
grow along stream edges--
this is a picture from
the same vantage point
before wolves and after wolves.
The willows are growing.
Well, willow is
perfect beaver habitat.
So the beavers come
into this area.
They use the willows
to make dams.
So whereas there was only
one beaver colony in all
of Yellowstone prior
to wolf reintroduction,
there is now up to 12.
So willow is rebounding.
Cottonwood is rebounding.
So there's been a
major effect, not just
on elk numbers, which are down
in Yellowstone by more than 50%
due to the presence of
wolves, but a big change
in the vegetation.
And that vegetation has a big
ripple effect on other species
in Yellowstone.
So just restoring one species--
a keystone, this apex predator,
the wolf-- has had a dramatic
effect on Yellowstone.
So the message I'd
like you to take
from that is that in
general-- and Yellowstone
shows this-- that
Nature is resilient.
These populations can
come bounding back
if they're given the chance.
Habitat, protection,
time-- populations
can rebound dramatically.
Let me pull a few more familiar,
maybe some familiar species out
of history for you,
give you these numbers.
And you'll know some
of these, certainly,
from the California coast.
Here's a set of species
that had game protection
at different times once their
numbers were severely depleted.
And here's where
they're at today.
So look at the
northern elephant seal.
It was down in the late 1800s
to as few as 20 individuals--
200,000 today.
Sea otter was down to as
few as 1,000 individuals
across the entire Pacific--
over 100,000 today.
Northern Pacific humpback--
same sort of effect--
tenfold increase.
Bald eagles since the
1960s-- 20-fold increase.
Gray wolf-- once re-introduced--
a lot more wolves now
in the whole greater
Yellowstone system.
So given a chance, Nature
is quite resilient.
Given that protection,
given habitat,
animal numbers can
come roaring back.
Now, these are
individual species
that were granted
individual protections.
What do we do in
the case of a place
where the whole habitat
has been deeply disturbed?
And I want to close
today with one story out
of a pretty special place
in the world-- special
because its history looked
so dire at one time.
And it's in Mozambique
in southeastern Africa.
Mozambique is a country about
double the area of California.
It has lots of natural areas.
But it's had a
really rough history.
So after its independence
from Portugal in 1975,
it went through a civil war.
And in the center of Mozambique,
really the geographic center,
is this park called Gorongosa.
And Gorongosa was
a gem in the 1960s.
It was a destination for
jet-setters like John Wayne
and all that going on safari,
and had big concentrations
of wildlife, like 500
lions and 15,000 buffalo
and a few thousand elephants,
a few thousand hippos, etc.
So out let me take you
back to the early 1960s.
I wish I had some of that
1960s music here for you.
But just a little clip of--
I know these vehicles still
roam California, but they
don't roam Gorongosa anymore.
So you see the lions
right out there.
And people were going
to see these lions.
And lions were the
symbol of Gorongosa
and there were 100s of them.
But then the civil
war broke out.
And unfortunately, Gorongosa was
one of the main battlefields.
It's where rebels
established a stronghold.
There were lots of
conflicts in Gorongosa.
And so many of the
large animals were
shot, either for
meat, for poaching,
or just as collateral
damage to the conflict.
So let me show you
the numbers of animals
before and after the war.
So before the war
is the blue bars.
You can see the buffalo
up there around 14,000.
We're down here
to fewer than 100.
Elephants in the
thousands-- again,
small numbers, hippos
decimated, waterbuck decimated,
zebra almost cleared out.
There were no detectable lions
in the park in the year 2000.
So this, I think, is decimation.
But that was the
way Gorongosa was
after the civil war, and the
way it would probably remain,
were it not for an American
philanthropist named
Greg Carr, who learned
about Mozambique,
learned about Gorongosa.
I wanted to show
you what Gorongosa
looked like at the time, too.
And this was the
status of the park.
All the buildings
were shot to pieces.
All the vehicles
But in 2004, Greg
Carr came along
and signed an agreement, a
joint management agreement,
with the Mozambique
government to try to restore
Gorongosa National Park.
And the goal was
really twofold--
to restore the park as an
economic engine in the area,
and to do a lot of
human development
around the park in the
form of clinics, schools.
Because the infrastructure
of Mozambique
had really been
abandoned-- neglected
for more than 30 years.
So Carr committed to a long-term
joint management project
with Mozambique.
He's now about 12
years into this.
I visited Gorongosa last summer.
So if you'll forgive me, this
is not quite National Geographic
quality film.
I'll tell you what's
going on in Gorongosa now.
I'm hanging out of a helicopter
with a handheld camera,
so give you some sense of
what this place is like.
So the major
feature of Gorongosa
is a huge lake at its
center called Lake Urema.
It fills and floods
during the wet season.
And then as that water shrinks,
and all the silt that's
been carried down from
the mountains is there,
it creates this giant
salad bowl which
we're kind of tilting over.
And you can see some of the dots
and some of the animals running
are largely water buck, out
feeding on this gigantic salad
bowl.
And you see these little fingers
of waterways through there.
There's a pretty good number
of crocs in Gorongosa.
But it's a very, very
different landscape
than the Serengeti, really
different relative numbers
of all sorts of different
kinds of species
that used to be there.
Now, this is what
you can see in 2015.
We're going to go out over
the water a little bit,
and give you a
little sense of else
is floating about Gorongosa.
You might just pick
them out there,
but here is a nice little group.
You guys make out
what those are?
Hippos, right.
You can find them
on Google image.
OK, just help me out.
And it's a pretty
big pod of hippos.
And we'll spin
around a little bit.
And then we'll go a little
deeper into the forest.
And I'll show you a little more
of the wildlife that's there.
And here you go-- so just
this group of elephants.
You can tell there's
a lot of youngsters
in here-- so a lot of young
elephants in Gorongosa today.
So how have the large
animal populations
changed in a dozen years?
Well, the baseline
was back in 2000,
when you combined all the
antelope, buffalo, hippos,
elephants, et cetera, fewer than
1,000 large animals combined.
In the last survey 71,000--
little more than a decade.
So a radical change,
a radical rebound--
and what was involved here was
a little bit of importation.
Carr brought in a
couple hundred buffalo,
brought in a few
elephants, a few hippos.
But largely, this is the
rebound of the populations that
were already there,
just by being protected
from any further exploitation.
So the success in Gorongosa has
prompted an even bolder vision.
It's a big park.
It's a vast place,
with lots and lots
of different kinds of habitats.
But Mozambique is a vast place.
And they'd like to have an
even greater protected area.
And so the vision for
Gorongosa is to expand it.
This is the current boundaries
of the park shown here--
is to expand it about eightfold,
create a giant conservation
area that will be about the size
of the Serengeti Conservation
Area in Tanzania--
an area large enough
to hold perhaps 10,000
elephants and about 500 lines.
And that endeavor
is now under way.
As far as the
Serengeti itself, I
am happy to report that
after years of deliberation,
the only roads going through the
Serengeti for now are unpaved.
And let's hope
they stay that way.
Thanks for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you,
this was a fantastic talk--
such a positive note.
We're open for questions now.
Please just point.
I'll bring the mic over.
So I suspect that small
amounts of hunting
don't really impact these
kinds of numbers very much,
but they do some.
But I'm wondering
about the trade off
between hunter-paid money to
these parks versus hunting,
and what your
thoughts are on that.
SEAN B. CARROLL: Yeah, so it's
a common practice in Africa
that there are
hunting concessions,
as these big lands
were carved up.
Some of these go
back many decades
that certain areas are
leased to concessionaires
that run hunting operations.
That can be an important source
of currency for management
in those countries.
We all know the
pretty famous case
of Cecil the lion, which
was not a good story.
But in the vast Gorongosa area,
in the map I just showed you,
there are, in fact, a
couple hunting concessions.
So as long as you know
what's being taken,
and there's some
reliable census,
you can sort of figure out what
amount of take can be managed.
In things like waterbuck, you'd
have to kill a lot of waterbuck
to probably dent the system.
When you think of top
predators, there's only
63 lions in Gorongosa today.
So that's just way too
few relative to history.
There are no leopards in
Gorongosa in the main park.
There are no hyena-- really
another important predator.
So certainly at
the moment, nobody
wants to see those
animals taken by hunting.
So it's just a part of, I
think, the practical reality--
that it's a source of revenue.
And revenue really matters
in these parts of the world.
But by the same token, the
deer hunt in Wisconsin,
which I think we issue 600,000
permits for a nine-day season
in November, that pays for
virtually all the management
activities of all the other
wildlife in the state.
So I think that, again, if you
have good scientific management
of those game populations, then
a certain amount of hunting
may be manageable.
In the Serengeti,
there's always wildebeest
being taken by the
native Tanzanians.
But as long as it doesn't exceed
maybe 20,000 or 30,000 animals
a year, it won't make a dent.
They'll actually be replenished.
So there's a certain amount
of sustainable hunting
that's possible.
AUDIENCE: Except for
your first example, which
is the biggest one, most
of the keystone species
are actually predators.
SEAN B. CARROLL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are
there special rules
about the non-predator
species being keystones?
And it seems like it's
harder to restore them.
It's more like an unusual
situation, possibly.
SEAN B. CARROLL: Yeah, I
think the non-predators
become keystones when they're
especially kind of what's
called ecosystem engineers.
So wildebeest, by mowing a
vast tract of the Serengeti,
have a big effect.
In the Himalayas, pica
are ecosystem engineers,
and they affect the
pattern of runoff.
And they create these burrows
that other animals live in.
So you can be a keystone
without being a predator.
But as it turns
out, these predators
that have these strong indirect
effects downstream of them--
only fairly recently we
started to appreciate
how important that is.
In fact, most ecologists thought
that the world was really
regulated from the
bottom up-- that plants
gathered sunlight and
converted it to food,
and that the whole system
flowed from the bottom up.
And maybe predators were--
if there was enough game
or enough prey around, that
they were sort of ornaments
on the tree, not really
imagining that predators
were driving the structure
of these systems, as starfish
do on the coast, or sea otters
do, or as other predators do,
like spiders do on plants.
I still think we're
still getting our heads
around the importance of
apex predators in the world.
There's still a
lot of primary work
in the scientific
literature calling attention
that these apex predators
also are generally
disproportionately exploited,
at a much higher rate
than other sorts of populations.
In the ocean, it's the big apex
predators like cod and tuna
that we like to eat.
And if we overfished
those, those
have huge cascading effects
down the line in the oceans.
So yeah, a lot are
apex predators.
And I think the
general mindset is
we've got to be a lot more
alert to what we're doing
to apex predator populations.
The history of this--
wolves, lions, coyotes,
things like this-- is we didn't
like them around-- humans
so we killed them.
And in the ocean
today, the predator
that's disappearing most rapidly
are sharks, from both finning
and from bycatch.
And there are people
who, of course,
care a lot about sharks.
But we don't have the same
kind of emotional reaction
to sharks that we have
to manatees, or tigers,
or leopards, or
things like that.
So we've got to be aware of
the role of apex predators.
I mean, look-- I
mean, sea otters--
this blew ecologists'
minds-- to think
that essentially the whole
coastal ecosystem depended
upon these furry little
predators eating those urchins.
Just turned people's
thinking upside down.
MALE SPEAKER: Other questions?
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering,
do you generally
find that you have one keystone
species in an ecosystem?
Or are there sometimes
none or sometimes many?
SEAN B. CARROLL:
Sometimes none--
so jobs seem to be sort
of parceled out a lot more
broadly-- sometimes multiple.
We're land dwellers,
so first, we
tend to study
terrestrial systems
with a certain amount of bias.
But out in the
ocean, it's kind of
hard to decide where
all the keystones are.
Because it's a fish
eat fish world.
You have really vast
webs of fish feeding
on other sorts of fish.
So we know that apex
predators are important.
But because almost everything
in the ocean's a predator--
every fish in the
ocean is a predator--
that you just have
really complex webs.
And there's no way to
sort of clearly pick out
and say, well, this
is a keystone that's
in a clean line
connected to just two
or three other sorts of things.
So there's lots of cascades
running in the ocean,
but not such clearly
delineated keystones.
MALE SPEAKER: All right, thank
you so much for the fantastic
talks.
SEAN B. CARROLL: Thanks, Google.
Now enjoy your
tuna and cod lunch.
Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: Would you be
staying for a few minutes
to sign any books?